[Musica]
sapete quando è stata la prima volta in
cui ho sentito i miei genitori fare
sesso
avevo 18 anni avranno aspettato tutto
questo tempo ho pensato
immagino di no e la prima volta in cui
ho comprato dei sex toys
avevo 19 anni tornavo dall'università e
con aria imbarazzata sono entrata dentro
in sexy shop tutta contenta per la
sorpresa che aveva fatto al mio
fidanzato sono tornate a casa tutto bene
fin quando mia madre un giorno in un
aprile armadio premetto che legge era a
conoscenza del fatto che io avessi dei
rapporti sessuali
io però furba dovevamo messo i miei
giochi in una pochette trasparente non
vi dico la sua faccia e gli insorti dopo
che si rese conto che non cercava di
occultare l'evidenza bene se non mi
conoscete già
mi presento mi chiamo federica federica
d'amore un cognome che sembra quasi un
destino nel mio caso questo nome oggi si
fonde con il mio nome d'arte da nick
amori creato per nascondere la mia
identità e nazionalità in un momento in
cui il mio pensiero ai miei numeri non
facevano la differenza di fronte a chi
mi osservava da nico mori ha osato
sfidare osato sfidare il pensiero comune
immaginarsi e immaginarsi vincente in un
ambiente di economia psicologia a
prescindere da un passato nel porno beni
che morì a danni che morì quella parte
di me stessa che ha osato dissentire e
che è che ha portato avanti un pensiero
laterale da nick amori vuole anche un pò
somigliare al mio vero cognome da mori
da amore
ora per citare un grande regista voglio
dirvi che le parole sono importanti la
parola porno lo è
essa deriva infatti dal greco porne
meretrice e dal verbo fermi io vendo
queste parole allegati disse rubil mente
l'attività di porno attrice a quella di
prostituta ed effettivamente entrambe
vendiamo una prestazione sessuale
questa parola però è scalfita è
connotata nelle nostre menti come
qualcosa di negativo se sarà quindi
volevo introdurre il concetto di sex
worker
ma cos'è un sex worker un sex worker è
una persona che lavora nell'industria
del sesso
ogni tanto mi piace ogni tanto mi piace
andare in giro per il blog delle
statistiche di pornhub e confrontarmi
con un po di numeri o guardare
all'interno della community e rendermi
conto che come me
esattamente a tantissime altre persone
migliaia di altre persone e credono che
farci vedere come mamma li ha fatti non
mette in discussione il valore della
loro personalità della loro identità ma
la statistica che ti mi fa sorridere e
pensare è quella in cui viene mostrato
che cosa accade in un minuto su pornhub
mentre vi state a proprio in grande a
fare la vostra ricerca sono state già
fatte oltre 77.000 ricerche oltre
200.000 visite oltre 130 messaggi
inviati 12 gigabyte di dati trasferiti
ti ho detto questo in un solo minuto ed
in un solo sito
ecco adesso per tornare a noi o meglio a
van eyck amori ciò che sono oggi lo devo
l'idea che ho di vita e di libertà che
mi ha portato a sperimentare la mia
storia come individui e come coppia
ho vinto per due anni di seguito e due
premi ai pornhub awards e in due delle
categorie più i nominabili nella nella
storia della stampa i miei video i miei
video contano oltre un miliardo e mezzo
di visualizzazioni
sono una pornostar e atipica vengo
tecnicamente definito come materiale in
quanto tutta la la produzione delle
video avviene in un ambiente intimo
nell'ambiente intimo di casa mia e
soprattutto della coppia stefano o
meglio steve mori e la persona con cui
condivido questa storia d'amore
pornografica e di cui sono i numeri
innamorata da oltre 12 anni
insieme abbiamo iniziato questo percorso
e non avremmo mai immaginato di ottenere
tanta attenzione da un pubblico globale
da ispirare milioni di persone ma come
siamo arrivati fino a questo volevo oggi
farvi immaginare di avere una scatola e
dentro questa scatola fate finta ci sia
il mondo le vostre idee
tutto quello che conoscete cosa ho fatto
ho distrutto la scatola o distrutto per
ricostruire perché questo e poi
esattamente la spiegazione della frase
che noi tutti conosciamo think outside
box pensa fuori dalla scatola perché
bisogna essere capaci di cambiare idea e
ricostruire e non stancarsi mai di
ricostruire perché non possiamo credere
che la prima scatola che costruiamo sia
quella poi definitiva per la nostra
identità
esattamente con l'approccio di un
bambino dovremmo buttarci fare la nostra
scelta che lasciare che sia l'esperienza
a formarci ad aggiungere un pezzo al
puzzle della nostra identità oggi sono
una leader il mio lavoro sono manager
modella a volte anche psicologa e
tecnico informatico ma quando ero
bambina e mi immaginavo come leader di
certo non devo orgasmi software per
editing creazione di contenuti digitali
se prima ho osato sfidare il pensiero
generale che vede il sex worker solo ed
esclusivamente come la deturpazione di
un corpo di una volontà ed in etica
sociale comune
oggi vi sfido a rivedere la funzione che
ha l'educazione sessuale nella nostra
società e il ruolo dei sex worker perché
in una società in cui la sessualità
viene vista come parte integrante della
nostra identità e in cui si fa
educazione sessuale
il porno non rischierebbe più di essere
l'unico insegnante veicolo magari di una
visione manipolata del sesso è per
questo che credo che ognuno di noi debba
sperimentare la propria realtà sessuale
ed è per questo motivo che sono convinta
che c'è bisogno di una comunicazione più
aperta che sia slegata dai dai vecchi
binari smi le vecchie etichette e che
abbiano approccio più inclusivo fondato
sul piacere e sull'autodeterminazione
[Applauso]
[Musica]